What is the reason for the pain in the left foot soul?
So are you saying you have pain in your left foot? Well, there could be
there could be a
hundred reasons for that
Did you injure the site did you you can so the left foot soul
Um, depends on where it is in your foot is it on the lateral side of your foot most common
cause of that is
Diffed metatarsal stress fracture, which is extremely common if you're working on country or walking and concrete all the time if it's on the
Medial side you could have you know arch issues to I mean all sorts of musculoskeletal things could be going on
Um, does cancer metastasize to your feet? Um, very very very rarely, you know, you don't think that's a concern even
Enter into the mind of an oncologist
So um, there's just all sorts of musculoskeletal things that could be going on good thing to go to a chiropractor or somebody
Who could maybe take some x-rays and see what's going on do an examination